le président démocrate dans la tourmente
chaotique ce qualificatif est revenu
avec force lorsque les plumes des médias
américains et internationaux ont évoqué
les conséquences du retrait des forces
américaines en afghanistan le
responsable numéro 1 est tout désigné
joe biden que l'on trouve cela juste ou
injuste l'histoire retiendra que joe
biden est celui qui a présidé à la
conclusion humiliante de l'expérience
américaine en afghanistan
le retrait n'aurait pas dû dégénéré en
un spectacle catastrophique le président
aurait pu écouter les nombreux avis
éclairés de ses conseillers
après la prise de pouvoir des talibans
sa cote de popularité a même chuté de
sept points selon un sondage reuters
ipsos avec 46 % d'américains satisfaits
de son action elle est au plus bas
depuis sa prise de fonction pour steven
rogers ex officier du renseignement de
la marine américaine l objectif en
afghanistan n'a pas été atteint
l'objectif était de s'assurer que le
gouvernement afghan soit fort que ce
soit un pays où les gens seraient libres
un pays gouverné par une constitution et
non pas par un dictateur ou une
organisation terroriste
l'objectif on n'a jamais été atteint 20
ans de travail pour finalement assister
à une catastrophe
comment peut-on abandonné tous ces gens
derrière nous je parle des citoyens
afghans qui connaîtront des tortures
d'enfants et des meurtres
l'accord signé en 2020 par son
prédécesseur donald trump avec les
talibans ne laissait qu'une marge de
manoeuvre réduite à joe biden confirmé
le retrait ou provoquer une nouvelle
escalade mais plus que la décision du
retrait en elle-même c'est la manière
ainsi que le manque de vision sur la
rapidité de l' offensive talibane qui
alimentent l'idée de débâcle sur sa
ligne de défense by donne le concède lui
même cet art très difficile et
désordonnée mais il justifie coûte que
coûte sa décision sa stratégie tirer à
boulet rouge sur le fatalisme des forces
afghanes
nous leur avons donné toutes les chances
de déterminer leur propre avenir ce que
nous ne pouvions pas leur fournir était
la volonté de se battre pour cet avenir
et fight finale fut
émis mauricie l'afghanistan est
incapables d'opposer une résistance aux
talibans maintenant il n'y a aucune
chance qu'un en un an de plus cinq ans
de plus ou vingt ans de plus de présence
américaine sur place aurait fait la
moindre différence
mais face à la force de l'image les mots
du locataire de la maison blanche n'ont
pas pesé lourd reste désormais à savoir
dans quelle mesure ces événements
affecteront la suite du mandat de joe
biden
à la crise afghane et sa gestion par un
joe biden qui n'ont pas manqué de faire
réagir son prédécesseur donald trump on
écoute
vas y donne a totalement échoué sur la
pandémie et il supervise maintenant la
plus grande humiliation en matière de
politique étrangère dans l'histoire des
états unis d'amérique
c'est la plus grande humiliation que je
n'ai jamais vu
la sortie bâclé de baden en afghanistan
est la démonstration la plus étonnante
d'incompétence grossière de la part d'un
leader national peut être même que
personne n'ait jamais vu
nommer une autre situation comme celle
ci le vietnam ressemble un cours
magistral de stratégie comparée à la
catastrophe de joe biden et cela n'avait
pas se produire tout ce qu'il avait à
faire était de laisser les soldats sur
place jusqu'à ce que tout soit sorti nos
citoyens nos armes puis de bombarder les
bases nous avons cinq bases et vous dit
bye bye